dans toute l'histoire du Honduras.
Maintenant, grâce à ELAM, ils sont 69.
Aux grands maux, les grands remèdes,
suscités par de grandes idées, de l'imagination et de l'audace,
Mais aussi des remèdes qui fonctionnent.
L'université ELAM n'avait pas de matériel pratique
pour les guider, ils ont donc appris sur le tas,
par la pratique et en corrigeant les cours au fur et à mesure.
Même les étudiants les plus brillants
venant de ces communautés pauvres
n'étaient pas suffisamment préparés
pour six ans d'études de médecine.
Un cours de rattrapage en sciences a donc été créé.
Ensuite, la langue :
ils étaient Mapuche, Quechuas, Guarani, Garifuna,
des peuples indigènes,
qui avaient appris l'espagnol comme seconde langue,
ou des Haïtiens qui parlaient créole.
L'espagnol est donc devenu une partie
du programme de préparation aux études de médecine.
Malgré tout, à Cuba,
la musique, la nourriture, les odeurs,
tout était différent,
l'université est devenue la famille, ELAM, le foyer.
Les religions allaient des croyances indigènes
au Yoruba, à l'Islam et Chrétien évangélique.
Accepter la diversité devint un mode de vie.
Pourquoi tant de pays
ont demandé ces bourses ?
D'abord, ils n'ont pas assez de médecins,
et là où il les ont, leur répartition
ne profite pas aux pauvres,
parce que notre crise sanitaire globale
est due à une crise des ressources humaines.
Il nous manque 4 à 7 millions de travailleurs de santé
juste pour combler les besoins de base,
et le problème est partout.
Les médecins sont concentrés dans les villes,
où seulement la moitié de la population mondiale vit,
et à l'intérieur des villes,
pas dans les bidonvilles ou South L.A.
Ici aux États-Unis,
avec la réforme du système de santé,
nous n'avons pas assez de professionnels.
D'ici 2020, il nous manquera
45 000 médecins généralistes.
Nous sommes aussi responsables du problème.
Les États-Unis sont le premier importateur
de médecins venant des pays émergents.
La deuxième raison pour laquelle les étudiants ont afflué à Cuba
est le bulletin de santé de l'île,
qui repose sur de forts soins de base.
Une commission de The Lancet classe Cuba
parmi les meilleurs pays à revenu intermédiaire en termes la santé.
Save the Children classe Cuba
comme le meilleur pays en Amérique Latine pour avoir un enfant.
Cuba a une espérance de vie équivalente
et moins de mortalité infantile que les États-Unis,
avec moins de disparités,
alors que les dépenses par personne
sont un vingtième de ce que
nous dépensons ici aux États-Unis.
Académiquement, ELAM est difficile,
mais 80 % de ses étudiants obtiennent leur diplôme.
Les sujets sont les mêmes -
sciences cliniques et de base -
mais il y a des différences majeures.
D'abord, la formation est sortie de sa tour d'ivoire
pour aller dans les classes cliniques et les quartiers,
là où la plupart de ces diplômés iront pratiquer.
Bien sûr, ils ont des cours et des internats aussi,
mais l'apprentissage communautaire commence dès le début.
Deuxièmement, les étudiants traitent complètement le patient,
le corps et l'esprit,
dans le contexte de sa famille, sa communauté
et sa culture.
Troisièmement, ils apprennent la santé publique :
pour évaluer l'eau potable, l'habitation,
les conditions économiques et sociales de leurs patients.
Quatrièmement, on leur apprend
qu'une bonne consultation
et un examen clinique approfondi
fournissent la plupart des indices pour le diagnostic,
en ne gardant les technologies coûteuses pour la confirmation.
Enfin, on leur apprend sans cesse
l'importance de la prévention,
surtout alors que les maladies chroniques
paralysent les systèmes de santé dans le monde entier.
Une telle formation continue
est accompagnée d'une approche d'équipe,
autant pour travailler en équipe
que pour les diriger,
avec une dose d'humilité.
Après leur diplôme, ces docteurs partagent
leur savoir avec les infirmières, sages-femmes,
travailleurs sociaux,
pour les aider à devenir meilleurs dans leur métier,
pas pour les remplacer,
pour travailler avec les chamans et les guérisseurs traditionnels.
Les diplômés d'ELAM :
confirment-ils cette audacieuse expérience ?
Des dizaines de projets nous donnent un aperçu
de ce qu'ils sont capables d'accomplir.
Prenons les diplômés garifunas.
Ils ne sont pas rentrés chez eux que pour exercer,
mais ont encouragé leurs communautés à construire
le premier hôpital indigène du Honduras.
Avec l'aide d'un architecte,
les habitants l'ont littéralement construit à partir de rien.
Les premiers patients sont arrivés
en décembre 2007,
et depuis, l'hôpital a accueilli
presque un million de patients.
Et le gouvernement s'y intéresse,
considérant l'hôpital comme un modèle
pour la santé publique rurale du Honduras.
Les diplômés d'ELAM sont malins,
forts et aussi dévoués.
Haïti, janvier 2010.
La souffrance,
des gens sous 30 millions de tonnes de gravats.
Bouleversant.
340 médecins cubains
étaient déjà sur place depuis longtemps.
D'autres étaient en route, mais pas assez.
A l'ELAM, les étudiants travaillaient nuit et jour
pour contacter 2000 diplômés.
Finalement, des centaines arrivèrent à Haïti.
Provenant de 27 pays, du Mali au Sahara
de Sainte-Lucie, de Bolivie, du Chili et des États-Unis.
Ils communiquaient ensemble en espagnol,
et écoutaient les patients qui parlaient créole
grâce aux étudiants en médecine haïtiens
venus d'ELAM.
Beaucoup sont restés des mois,
malgré l'épidémie de choléra.
Des centaines de diplomés haïtiens
ont dû recoller les morceaux,
surmonter leur propre chagrin
et reprendre le fardeau de construire
un nouveau système de santé publique à Haïti.
Depuis, grâce aux ONG et aux gouvernements,
de la Norvège, à Cuba en passant par le Brésil,
des dizaines de centres de santé
ont été construits, fournis en personnel,
et 35 sont dirigés par des diplômés de l'ELAM.
L'histoire haïtienne illustre aussi
certains des plus gros problèmes
rencontrés dans de nombreux pays.
Regardez de plus près :
748 diplômés haïtiens en 2012, pendant l'épidémie de choléra
La moitié travaillant dans les hôpitaux publics,
un quart étant sans emploi
et 110 ayant quitté Haïti.
Donc dans le meilleur des cas,
les diplômés intègrent et ainsi renforcent
le système de santé publique,
où ils sont souvent les seuls médecins présents.
Dans le pire des cas, il y a un manque de postes à pourvoir
dans le secteur de la santé publique
où les plus pauvres sont soignés,
un manque de volonté politique, un manque de moyens,
un manque de tout !
il y a trop de patients non-soignés.
Les docteurs font aussi face à la pression de leurs familles,
qui cherchent à joindre les deux bouts,
s'il n'y a pas de travail dans le secteur public,
ces nouveaux docteurs vont travailler dans le privé
ou partent à l'étranger et envoient de l'argent à la maison.
Pire que tout, dans certains pays,
des sociétés médicales influencent les organismes d'accréditation
pour ne pas considérer le cursus ELAM.
Apeurés, ces jeunes docteurs prendront ces emplois
ou réduiront la charge de patients et leur revenu.
Ce n'est pas une question de compétences.
Ici, aux États-Unis, le conseil médical de Californie
a approuvé l'école après une étude rigoureuse,
et les nouveaux médecins font du bien
sur le grand pari de Cuba,
en réussissant leurs examens,
et en étant acceptés dans des établissements respectés
de New York à Chicago en passant par le Nouveau Mexique.
Ils sont 200, et ils reviennent
aux États-Unis pleins d'énergie,
et aussi agacés.
Comme l'un d'eux le dit :
« A Cuba, nous sommes formés à fournir des soins de qualité
avec un minimum de moyens.
Alors quand je vois tous les moyens disponibles ici,
et que vous me dites que c'est impossible,
je sais que c'est faux.
Non seulement j'en ai été témoin, mais je l'ai moi-même expérimenté. »
Les diplômés de l'ELAM,
certains venant d'ici-même, de Washington et Baltimore,
proviennent des familles les plus démunies.
Ils viennent offrir la santé et l'éducation,
et sont les porte-parole pour leur communauté.
Ils ont fait le gros du travail.
Maintenant, nous devons faire notre part
et soutenir les 23 000 et plus.
Nous tous -
fondations, responsables des internes, médias,
entrepreneurs, responsables politiques, le peuple...
nous devons monter au créneau.
Nous devons en faire beaucoup plus
pour donner à ces nouveaux médecins l'opportunité
de prouver leur courage.
Ils doivent être capables de participer aux examens de leur pays.
Ils ont besoin d'emplois dans le secteur de santé publique,
dans des centres de santé,
pour mettre leur formation et leur engagement en pratique.
Il faut qu'ils puissent devenir
les médecins dont leurs patients ont besoin.
Pour aller de l'avant,
il faut peut-être revenir un peu en arrière,
à ce pédiatre qui était venu
sonner chez mes parents
dans le Sud de Chicago quand j'étais petite,
qui faisait des visites à domicile,
au service du public.
Il n'y a pas tant d'idées nouvelles
sur ce que devrait être la médecine.
La nouveauté, c'est le changement d'échelle.
Le visage des médecins a aussi changé :
un diplômé de l'ELAM est plus souvent une femme
qu'un homme.
En Amazonie, au Pérou, ou au Guatemala,
un médecin indigène,
aux États-Unis, un médecin de couleur
qui parle espagnol couramment.
Elle est bien formée, fiable,
et partage le visage et la culture de ses patients
et elle mérite amplement notre soutien,
car que ce soit en métro, à dos d'âne ou en canoë,
elle nous apprend à joindre le geste à la parole.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)